monsieur
vous êtes en train de me faire là un
bonhomme de neige mais pourquoi
l'honneur
nettoyer la vitre c'est ça
c'est pour les fêtes et oui non mais moi
je vous ai pas demandé de me faire un
bonhomme de neige alors vous arrêtez un
père Noël je veux rien du tout
c'est quoi ça un père Noël attends j'ai
pas fini
mais arrêtez je vous dis il faut pas
faire ça mais je le fais tout seul je
suis dessinateur moi c'est pas vrai
vas-y fais moins un truc
pour les fêtes quand même c'est plus
c'est plus gai
pas après mes vitres c'est clair ce que
je te dis t'écris pas d'accord d'accord
dessine alors tu fais rien du tout tu
fais rien d'accord
non tu comprends pas ce que je te dis si
tu te fous de ma gueule ou tu le fais
exprès vous
occupez pas qui c'est qui va me faire
un bon père Noël non monsieur je veux
rien du tout un beau père Noël un
bonhomme de neige
là vous avez un karcher je vais t'en
mettre un karcher
dans la gueule un karcher tout à l'heure
ça va main libre et je comprends pas
[Musique]